montigny le bretonneux a enregistré le
retour d'un enfant du club pascal lucky
33 ans passé par versailles quand on
entre fréjus et le canada a décidé de
revenir dans son club de coeur une
structure qui l'a vu réaliser ses
premiers dribbles et ses premiers
paniers à trois points en poussins à
l'âge de 10 ans je pense qu'à un moment
donné quand tu as fait beaucoup clubs
différents août avait des objectifs
j'aime bien sportif que personnel voilà
revenir à quelque chose où tu joue
vraiment avec des amis 500 sont
différentes et moi c'est vraiment ce que
je voulais ressentir cette année j'avais
des possibilités partir d'août l'homme
mais il est vraiment dans la revenir
revenir chez moi et jouer avec mes amis
beaucoup arrivé avec un statut de joueur
d'expérience parce qu'elle le qui a
réalisé un début de saison tonitruant
avec une moyenne de 15 points 5 passes
et 5 rebonds par match lenny montain
s'épanouit à son poste d'arrière à
l'image de ses idoles moi je suis né en
83 donc j'ai grandi avec la génération
jordan cagoule et settat donc voilà
c'est vraiment le premier sportif on va
dire qu'il m'a dit m'a inspiré
après derrière feu lui qui ressemblait
le plus à ce qu'il faisait c'était kobe
bryant et voilà pourquoi aussi pour moi
fait les deux joueurs qui sont uniques
et donges et vous poussez de m'inspirer
d'enjeux dans la manière d'être dans le
leadership est tous sur le plan
collectif son arrivée coïncide avec le
renouveau de montigny le bretonneux
l'équipe en difficulté depuis plusieurs
saisons occupent les premières places du
championnat prérégional avec un bilan de
cinq victoires et deux défaites vu qu'il
a joué dans un niveau supérieur qui est
il prenait déjà pour réussir et koné les
clés
naturellement c'est un joueur de de bons
niveaux de haut niveau donc dans les
moments clés dans les matches qui sera
assez vite y est là pour mettre les
shoots qui peut faire la différence le
fait de revenir au club va nous fait un
gros plus sur le terrain et en dehors du
terrain aussi tout ce qui est conseils
pour y aider un peu les joueurs après
avoir remis avec ses coéquipiers
montigny sur les rails pascal leu qui
espère ramener le titre en fin de saison
et guider l'équipe vers les portes de la
nationale dans les deux à trois
prochaines années
[Musique]